[Music]
he's intimacy avoidant with me
acts out regularly with ex-girlfriends
he has chosen to continue a series of
destructive behaviors that are blowing
up his life and most importantly the one
woman he said was going to be his one
woman
[Music]
what's up this is john with the dr john
dolone's show the greatest mental health
podcast of all time
says nobody ever hey we're so glad that
you're with us uh talking about mental
health relationships school school
whatever's going on in your world in
your life uh it's summer time now so
maybe you're not thinking about school
which is probably a good thing
uh if you want to be on the show give me
a buzz at one eight four four six nine
three thirty two ninety one or go to
johndaloni.com
ask
a-s-k
um
i just left a meeting here and i wanted
to pass this along
one of the most
common
sources of angst right now i'm hearing
from folks
is about inflation
is about the
stock market the real estate thing i
know this is a mental health show not a
money show but those those
your mental health and your financial
health are intimately braided together
they are woven together
and
one of the things i'm hearing is that
this is good what we're experiencing
right now this is going to come out in
july mid july
is we're experiencing the same thing
that happened in o708 which is in this
gonna be like the 20s all everything's
going to implode and i want us to
remember about what trauma does
trauma puts a gps pin in a moment
in an experience that we have whether
it's an abusive relationship or the car
wreck or the dad got home and beat us up
or dad got home and yelled at us our dad
got home and ignored us right it puts a
gps pin in those moments
and our bodies remember
so if you live through 0708 or if you
were a kid if you're in middle school
high school and your parents lived
through a 708
and the value of your home
cut in half
but your mortgage didn't
or you were one of your parents or you
were one of the millions who were laid
off from their jobs and literally
couldn't find work and had to move
states just to find a job of any sort
right
your body remembers that
and so if you're feeling stressed right
now you should be your body's doing its
job it's reminding you hey there's a
lion here and it might eat us
if you are 50 or 60 or 70 you remember
the 70s my first savings account was at
13
that's what i made on my savings account
when i was a child we were coming out of
the and that was in the 80s we're coming
out of this wild inflationary period in
the 70s
early 80s
if you were if your body remembers those
moments you remember that having a house
a mortgage at 18
interest at 15 right so all here's what
i'm saying
all this stuff's important because your
body's trying to tell you hey we're not
safe we're not safe we're not safe and
you dump on top of that
a media ecosystem that is designed for
one thing and one thing only
not to give you truth
not to give you in not not to give you
uh wisdom
it's designed to sell
ads and it sells ads by getting you to
click on things and it gets you to click
on things by telling you it's all coming
down
because remember as we talked about the
show over and over we if it can if we
can point you towards there's a bear
there might be a bear there might be a
bear check click here to find out your
bot your brain is going to go i got to
know i got to know i got to know all i
have to say is this
the real estate market for folks is
bananas it's gone up like crazy it's
continuing to go up like crazy and
everybody's asking should i buy a house
i've got to sell this thing everything's
about to implode it's going to crash
the data suggests
relatively clearly
that what's happening right now is
nothing like what happened to no 708
nothing
and
for the millions and millions of people
who are sitting on the sidelines
thinking i'm just going to wait for a
year and then i'm going to buy a house
at half price it's not going to happen
that way so here's what we got
um you all know that um my good friend
dave ramsey rachel cruz george campbell
um
we've got they're putting out a live
stream event that's going to be for free
for folks to get some data facts are
your friends remember we say that all
the time control what you can control
all those those little slogans that we
throw when people are stressed when they
are dealing with trauma when they're
when their bodies are taking off on them
when they're anxious when they're when
they're buzzing right
they're gonna answer all of your
questions and unpack real actual data in
this live stream okay it's for free
costs you nothing it's a gift to
humanity to say hey whoa whoa whoa
everybody calm down and listen if it's
the reverse if the data was telling us
oh this is about to implode we do the
same thing like me and my buddies would
be telling you hey this one's for real
you got to watch out so remember this
stuff
fax your friends buying a house is
emotional right now what's going on in
our ecosystem with the with the media
and with the
inflation ah pull politics at
exhale i know it's scary i live it too i
live it too i just lost out on a place
behind my house hold up i'm in the
middle of it with you okay
register for free
it's gonna be called real estate reality
check
register for the free real estate
reality check live stream at
ramseysolutions.com
slash reality check
that's it ramsay solutions.com
reality check
it's going to be an hour that's it you
can devote an hour of your life
to getting some true data and exhaling
the date is where's july 14th right so
it's july 14th
real estate reality check
ramseysolutions.com
reality check go check it out
and by the way
let this be a primer
anytime your body takes off on you just
stop and say where can i get some truth
where can i get some real information
here i'm gonna examine these feelings
examine these thoughts and ask myself is
this true
and if you don't know if it's true then
go get some data right so that's what
we're doing for you for free or i'm not
doing it that's what my buddies are
doing for you all right that's enough of
that so let's go to uh ann in
los angeles what's up anne
hey dr john um i want to start by saying
thank you for all that you do um i
actually do think you have the greatest
mental health podcast in the world yeah
so i think you're awesome and i
appreciate the work that you're doing
for people mom is this you
just kidding thank you ann thank you run
go do your laundry
that would be my wife who actually said
those exact words today all right so
what's up man how are we doing
uh well i've i've had better days i'm
not doing great if i'm being honest but
i have a kind of a two-part yeah thank
you i've got a two-part question
um
how can i care for myself and shield my
children from major trauma while
choosing to remain in a marriage with my
sex addict husband
and then also what more can i do to
support him my husband's recovery
without further neglecting myself and my
needs
oh
man
so tell me about the sex addiction
yeah so
we've been married for eight years we
have two kids they're ages four and five
two boys
and he has struggled with the sex
addiction and intimacy disorders since
well before i met him um he's intimacy
avoidant with me um you know acts out
regularly with
ex-girlfriends former affair partners
sex workers you name it a lot of online
infidelity emotional infidelity and
physical infidelity um he does have
significant childhood trauma childhood
sexual trauma tragic loss of his father
at a very young age i also have
significant childhood trauma which i'm
sure doesn't help the situation at all
i'm a big old seven on the aces um score
but my husband has really short periods
of sobriety um followed by a relapse
every like year to 18 months on average
he's in and out of therapy with his csat
a certified sex addiction therapist
and currently not in therapy display to
relapse about six weeks ago
and i'm just living my life in a
constant state of hyper vigilance uh i
have severe ptsd nightmares panic
attacks
triggering episodes
what's happening hold on it's happening
right now take a breath take a breath
take a big deep breath and hold it for a
second okay
and let it out
so
so really i'm just trying to navigate
um you know how to
be a mom to my two kids be a
um
devoted and supportive wife and walking
alongside him and his um
his journey of recovery because he's
he's not a bad person he's a really
traumatized person and he you know has
uses
his his coping
mechanism is unfortunately a sex
addiction which is extremely
traumatizing for a relationship
um okay so let me hop in here let me hop
in here okay hop in here
i
am gonna
do a couple of things here
i'm gonna tell you some hard truths is
that fair is that cool
yeah
and i'm gonna say some things that i
know the internets are not gonna like
is that cool
sure yes okay
um and you can
take what i'm gonna say
and say that guy's an idiot he's full
he's a [ __ ] or
you can sit with it for a season okay
but what i'm gonna say is heart
the first thing is
your husband's childhood trauma is very
very real
so is yours
seven on the aces score is astounding
that's really high
yeah
and
he has a choice
and so far
he has chosen
to not be about healing
he has chosen
to continue a series of destructive
behaviors that are blowing up his life
multiple other women's lives and most
importantly the one woman
he said was gonna be his one woman
oh but and two little boys who are
growing up looking at this
play-by-play saying this is what being a
man looks like this is what being a
caring loving husband looks like this is
what being a caring loving father looks
like
so
when you talk about trauma the language
you use
is a very common narrative in our
culture right now which is if this stuff
happened to you you are
you are de facto broken
as though you got in a car wreck
and you smash the bumper and that
bumper's always gonna look like that
and i am telling you that that is false
it's a hundred percent wrong
and where i know this is gonna be hard
the way i'm saying this and i apologize
but i don't apologize okay
it's really easy for you
to lump into to fall into that
to take his behaviors
and say but it's because of
because if you don't you have to look in
the mirror and say my husband is
continuing to choose other women over me
despite how much it hurts me
he's continuing to abandon his kids
emotionally and um
just his whole his whole
parental
in every way possible
and so it's actually it's a it's a
soothing force it's a it's a lotion it's
a bomb to say but it's because of this
and so i need you to hear me say across
all addictions
there is no relational healing when some
with an addict
until the addict gets clean
it doesn't exist
so if somebody comes into a therapy
session and they're drunk they have to
leave or they're an alcohol they have to
leave until and get clean
and then they can go do the work
but right now your husband's choosing to
remain connected to his addiction
not get well and heal and so ultimately
you can't control him you can only
control you
and i say this very very rarely
but you need to have a hard look at the
at the ecosystem you're raising those
boys in and you have to have a hard look
at your marriage
yeah
is that fair
yes
is your childhood trauma
one of
neglect and abandonment or fixing
absolutely yeah okay
so this whole thing feeds a narrative
that your body knows it feeds a story
that your body
has been down before right and so part
of you getting out of this thing is you
deciding to get well
yes is it fair
absolutely yeah
i'm so i'm heartbroken for you
and you could probably hear my voice i'm
mad at him i've never met him and i as a
rule i don't get mad at addicts i get
heartbroken about addicts
um
this one feels different to me
this one feels something feels off about
this
um and i'm just i'm just frustrated for
you i'm heartbroken for you mad for you
all those things
i can hear it but i think that's that's
one of the things i struggle with is
when i do approach a conversation with
some professionals or
in the times that i've tried to share
with friends or the very few family that
i have because i'm mostly estranged from
my family um i've i've lost
support systems because of
an attitude of
he's just a jerk a sex addiction isn't a
real thing and then when i you know when
i work with his
his um his actual sex education
therapist and i learn and educate myself
on the cycles and and
i
i see it differently but i find myself
isolating um because i is such a
um
misunderstood
conditions not the right word but
misunderstood addiction that i'm finding
myself just completely isolated because
talking about it brings more shame for
me but also the fear of
pushing people away or or
people having an image of our family and
and of him you know i want to protect
him too which i should probably
shouldn't care so much about that but
well but but you love him but here
here's the thing of course yeah
addiction just like other other issues
that we talk about here on the show a
lot
the addiction
is a context not an excuse
right you are being abused
your boys are being abused
okay
and he has an addiction
those two things are one does not cancel
the other out and one does not make the
other okay
but they can run simultaneously
so what that means is i might have to
leave this marriage but i'm not gonna
shoot him
i might have to leave this marriage but
i'm not going to
be bitter and raged out
i'm going to be heartbroken you see what
i'm saying like the resulting action may
be the same
how we ma maybe we're gonna parse out
there's a difference between being a
jerk and being someone who struggles
with addiction great
i still have to make sure that i'm well
and okay
and right now you're not
right and you deserve more than that
and yes your friends are knuckleheads
sexual addiction is very very real
and
i've been with not all there's some
extraordinary ones
but i've heard from addiction counselors
that once they classify you with an
addiction
it excuses all other behaviors and
everyone around you just has to tolerate
it all and that's nonsense too
yeah there comes a moment when somebody
is an addict
and they are hurting you let's just use
meth you're addicted to methamphetamines
and they keep coming home and they steal
from you and they are scary to be around
and they're up for four days and there's
holes in their face and there's holes in
the drywall and the kids are terrified
there's a moment when i say i love you
and
you cannot be here
you see what i'm saying
yes and so those are your i don't want
you to to lump all like addiction is not
a free pass on your safety and addiction
is not a free pass on the example your
boys are getting
right and you're gonna have to really
reckon with
this this marriage was gonna be the
thing that fixed you
your body is gonna feel this what's
happening right now if you choose to
leave this marriage your body's gonna
feel that as a
major trauma because it's gonna be a
trauma on top of one is that fair
absolutely yeah okay yeah i think that's
why i'm avoiding that exactly i almost i
would almost be willing to guarantee it
and i've just met you like three minutes
ago yeah but yes i would almost
guarantee it there's layers to this this
hurt for you
the question that you have to ask
yourself is what are you gonna do
and if you've made peace my husband just
sleeps with everybody ex-girlfriends
neighbors
sex workers whomever
that's who he is
if you make peace with it then make
peace with it and stop going to war
if you're not
then you have to own reality you have to
acknowledge the truth here which is he
has chosen to not get well for eight
years
he's chosen to not abstain from the
thing that is killing him that is
killing his wife then now it's going to
hurt his kids
and the question is what are you going
to do
right
yes and listen
please know you're not by yourself in
this i am heartbroken with you
it's my opinion that sex addiction is
one of the hardest addictions to clear
because it's so deeply woven into a a
need right a huge connection it's so
prevalent in society too you know the
internet has made things i think a lot
worse for abs absolutely
it's a mess alcohol you can remove it
from a household because you can't take
the internet away from the world you
can't take pretty women off the streets
you can't you know it's it's everywhere
it's like being addicted to water right
or it's like having disordered eating
challenges like you've got to make peace
with food because you can't just stop
eating forever you can stop cocaine
forever you can't stop it right so very
very similar here and you can't be
married and just avoid sex the rest of
your life too because you
intimacy is a cornerstone of a marriage
right so all that to say is
is a mess
there is healing i've seen it i've met
those people there's healing
um
his decision to go sleep with other
people is not a reflection of you
your inability to quote unquote fix him
does not mean you're failing
okay uh yeah i think on a cerebral level
i understand that intellectually um and
then emotionally
you know processing it and then really
accepting that is a little harder it is
i want you to this is going to be hard
and maybe spend some time with your
counselor writing this stuff down but
you haven't been on a 10-year failed
journey to fix some dude
and his desi
his choice to not be intimate with you
and to
not
truly try to get to the bottom of his um
addiction
it's not because you weren't pretty
enough
or because you weren't sexy enough
or because you didn't do the right
things or say the right things or walk
the right way
he's got stuff in his heart and his head
and his experiences that are heavy and
hard no question about it
but that's not a context for abuse
that's not a context for hurting you
it's not a con that's not a it's a
context not an excuse for abuse it's not
an excuse to hurt you and it's not an
excuse
to drag two little boys through this is
what manhood looks like and this is what
fathering and husband looks like
i'm so sorry it was one of those calls i
wish there was like some great
magic dust i could sprinkle on this one
this one's a mess this one's gonna be
hard it's gonna be tough to unwind
you're gonna have to get a professional
to walk with you
please do that because you
are worth more
we'll be right back
you all know there are lots of things
that make me nuts but one thing makes me
more nuts than anything else
buying a home and my friends who
refinance their homes they tell me it
makes them nuts too
i love living in a new home but i gotta
be honest
i'm no good at buying one and that's why
i'm so thankful for people like my
friends at churchill mortgage churchill
is a ramsey trusted provider who we've
been sending people to for over 20 years
to help with home mortgages why
because they're committed to doing
what's right for you and that means
walking you through paperwork that's way
over your head that means making sure
you get the right mortgage that you can
pay off as soon as possible and they'll
try to upsell you a bunch of nonsense
that's going to hurt you down the road
and most importantly when you're making
this big life change you can actually
breathe because you got an expert in a
team who have your back listen if you're
about to buy a home and make a big
change
save yourself the headache and call
churchill mortgage today at triple eight
loan 200. trust me that's triple eight
loan 200.
this is a paid advertisement in mls id
1591 nmls consumeraccess.org equal
housing lender 1749 mallory lane suite
100 brentwood tennessee 37027 programs
are for select loan types only and are
not available in all states or locations
all right we are back let's go to emma
in las vegas what's up emma
hi can you hear me i can can you hear me
yay yeah i can hear you hi john how are
you excellent you
yeah good man cool so what's up well
thanks for taking my call um so
hopefully this is an easy question
um what i'm kind of wanting some help
with is
asking for what i need in my marriage um
kind of
regarding like
my i don't know like asking for money
because i'm a stay-at-home mom with like
a little baby
and
um just also asking for a bit of help
around the house um or help with the
baby when my husband is home why why are
you asking for money
um because i don't have it in home and
oh but i should also elaborate um
unfortunately
my husband hasn't wanted to combine our
finances
um
and so
he kind of just
he has the bank account i don't really
have any
input with the finances at this point
which is a real bummer um
and so yeah i just kind of like when i
need groceries and things for the baby i
have to kind of tell them like oh i need
a hundred i need 50. i need this for
that you know and just kind of
a little bit by little bit ask for the
things that i need
emma do you hear that that's madness
yeah
i know that's really far from my deal um
no it's it's past that it's past that
again i don't want to
throw this word around flippantly
but that is really manipulative and
borderline abusive if not fully
because you're basically an employee
kinda yeah no no no not kind of you are
a living nanny
yeah
yes
that is not a marriage
that's not a partnership
no that makes sense that makes sense
yeah well what i i guess what i want is
like
i guess i want to try and figure out if
there's a way that you know by me being
a little bit more astertive
listen listen listen
one of the most common responses
oh man
um one of the most common no no no no
like i'm starting to feel my
my blood pressure's going up man
one of the most common responses to
abuse
is i shouldn't have worn that
or i was mouthing off and i deserved to
be hit
yeah or
i'm late sometimes so i deserve to be
fake fired every friday or whatever
um i deserve to be yelled at at work
because i'm not as fast as so and so
yeah
so
the reason
you are not um
your needs aren't not being met because
you're not assertive
right yeah now you could probably
improve your being assertive and you're
like i could be better at that that's a
skill that we could practice and work on
what we're just going for in your
marriage is just
basic
economic
equality
yeah i think i think that's what i uh
that's kind of probably
a lot of the reason why i feel so yucky
aside from the um you know aside from
the insecurity of like not not having
access to
to money for gas and groceries and
things but yeah it's kind of like oh i
just don't feel like he's treating me
like a partner like a wife like i kind
of feel like
it's almost like a daddy daughter thing
like it's one
let me put it this way every time i've
been a boss of a large team
they all had money that they spent
without like i don't i can't i can't
process all of your questions here's
your budget spend it on whatever you
need to run your operation i trust you
yeah i wouldn't have hired you yeah so
it's not even an employee employer
relationship it's a really
poor abusive employer employee
relationship
yeah well it's just like mother of his
kid
yeah
i know yeah well i mean do you laugh
listen you laugh are you laughing
because if you don't you may start
crying and you won't stop
oh yeah i mean okay yeah for sure i'm
just yeah i'm trying to keep light you
know like okay okay yeah because you
live in the darkness isn't it
it's a little bit
scary i guess because you know hold on
hold
on
this is terrifying
okay it's not a little bit scary it's
not a little bit scary
this is terrible no it is you're right
you don't know if you're gonna have
groceries or diaper money or gas money
yeah
are you safe
oh yeah i mean physically um physically
absolutely um and he's you know it's
weird because it's like it feels like
this is like quite a specific area so
like
he's never really raised his voice he's
obviously never gotten physical he he
never puts me down he you know like in
in
many regards like
if you take the money issue out of it
like i'd say you know on the face of
things it's quite a good relationship
there's a lot of like man if he just
didn't hit me it would be great right if
you just didn't sleep with my friends it
would be an awesome marriage yeah i mean
i wouldn't be putting up with any sort
of physical or
like major emotional stuff you know i am
but yeah have you ever said have you
ever sat down
have you ever sat down and said
um not in a fight not in a at a rage
but this is what i need
i need you to start treating me like a
partner here how did that conversation
go um
i think there was
he got very very uncomfortable i think
well i basically feel like look i would
i would feel a lot more comfortable if
we could combine our finances work on a
budget together um
and just talk more openly about money
and
give me you know access
access to money so that i don't have to
keep asking you yeah um
he just said
on the combining finances issue it was a
hard no um
he said like well you know i've been
married before and
um and she kept stealing money and like
i've got i've got it under control just
trust me um
you don't need to be involved don't
worry about it you're just really lucky
you don't have to go to work and i'm
taking care of it that was basically how
that went down
and so you hear like that of
you're the crazy one here hun yeah
that's not
that's not what i'm saying
like you're nuts that's that's
gaslighting 101.
oh you feel exposed because you have to
ask me for grocery money and for diaper
money for our kid and gas money you're
nuts you should realize how lucky you
are
to have me to ask you really like oh my
gosh
okay so listen i'm gonna tell you
something that is i have no data to back
up
okay um
i got a buddy who's been doing this a
long time
and working with people in their
finances
yes
a vast majority of the time in a
situation like this
where somebody won't combine finances
but on top of that
won't discuss it won't look at it
you have to ask for money there is some
sort of addiction or some sort of other
infidelity
there's something else going on that
says this is a brick wall that you
cannot cross
oh no i know what it is
i think
what is it maybe you should have led
with that what is that well
i'm
it's just kind of now that you say it um
because i have been wondering lately
like the past
year um i've been seeing some
sightseeing behaviors around alcohol and
it's not everyday drinking okay um
but
once in a while so every
three to four weeks on like a friday or
saturday um because we actually look
like on the outskirts of las vegas and
he'll go into las vegas says like if
there's business or work a saturday and
then he just won't come home um because
he's drinking it
hold on
or cause he's with somebody else
or that he's got he's got major gambling
issues or any number of other things
here here's what i'm talking about tell
me you used to have a gambling problem
so maybe that was it
okay i don't know here's here's the deal
emma ultimately this
we won't know that so any any energy we
spend wondering if it's another
girlfriend or if it's he's got a
gambling issue there in vegas or any any
of that energy is a waste of our time
yeah okay yeah yeah here's what we do
here's what we can focus on
i call it the or what statement
and everybody in your situation
anybody who's got a spouse who's doing
things that they that hurt them that
scare them that make them uncomfortable
all the way up to just annoying
they have to have an or what statement
and here's the or what statement
you have to fix your behavior spouse
or what
and so the question you have to ask
yourself is
if this goes on for another three months
another six months another six years
are you gonna leave
are you gonna stay now don't answer that
i just want you that's that's
if you're not gonna leave
if this is as good as you think your
life's gonna get
and you think he's being on the up and
up
and man it's annoying but i just i'm
gonna have to ask if i need to go get
lunch meat and grocery money and then
when little timmy needs clothes i'll
just ask and hopefully he'll give me
some
are you going to live that life
or
at some point are you going to say
enough's enough i'm out
because when you have
oh go ahead go ahead
i was just going to say i mean i've
given this you know a fair bit of
thought over there over there previous
months um yeah i don't i don't think
i don't feel like that's a particularly
good example to say to our to our little
one so i mean for now he's not aware
what what
you don't think you you don't think you
leaving is a good example or the way
you're being treated is a good example
no the way i'm being treated i don't
know what i don't want my son to watch
that
correct right but hey but listen to this
listen to this
ever held your little one
torment okay
please
absorb what i'm about to tell you okay
every time your husband comes home and
you don't feel safe
or you start performing
to try to get favor so you can get
grocery money
or you try to nuzzle up so you can get
gas money
or whatever your mechanisms are for
connecting
your heart rate goes up a little bit
your skin gets a little bit clammy
your
your chest gets tight your stomach gets
that warmth when you hear the garage
door open
your
four-year-old is absorbing every bit of
it
yeah okay so you think that that
four-year-old can't hear and can't
process and can't see or a
four-month-old
you think that you think that four
months old can't hear the words
that four that four-month-old is picking
up on everything yeah i know i think
about that too everything
now i don't say that to shame you i say
that to say
at some point you're gonna have to make
a call
and i see it happen all people punt the
call down the road and down the road
well now we're in middle school and we
gotta just let's just get through middle
school and then we can now that ninth
grade we got to graduate the high school
we started
right right it never is good
so
ultimately you have to get with a couple
of people in your life some women that
you trust a counselor of some sort a
church pastor who whatever wherever you
get wisdom and community from
yeah and you have to sit down and be
very concrete about your or what
statement
okay or what yeah and then you have to
be very clear about here's what i need
here's what i'm worth in a relationship
and we're gonna start
at
you're at work
wonderful
you get hammered and you don't come home
for a couple of nights
down in vegas cool yeah um i'm raising
the kid
and i'm making sure the kids fed and at
the doctor's appointment when i have gas
money that you've so graciously passed
along to me um i make sure that we're
all the houses fed when i'm so blessed
that you give me grocery money oh that's
so great and generous
right
right you hear i'm saying
i do i i hear it back and i just feel
like it's madness it's madness yeah it's
it's not it's not that i've put up with
it for any amount of time that i mean i
guess here we are so i just want to
try and yeah it's trying to strategize
about what is the the best way
forward it's not like the best way out
of this necessarily about the best way
for it and i'm not i'm not against
believing i have
plenty of family and
friends and you know options like so let
me tell you guys i could absolutely do
it but actually sorry it's very rare
it's
man
i feel like i'm debbie downer today it's
very rare that somebody who treats
people like this out
as a way of being
is able to have somebody lay their
relational needs out and they go oh my
gosh i was way off
my bad
that's pretty rare
i wish i could give you
data to the uh i mean otherwise
um
man what a mess
i think for the fir
hear me say this you're not crazy
that angst you feel that fear you feel
you're not crazy you're not
what's being done to you is wrong
it's not right
it's not how wives or husbands should
treat their wives it's not how husbands
should treat their kids
it's not right
and i'm sorry
ma'am
my hope is you sit down and say hey
here's what i need or i'm out i need
this from you and i need you to learn
how because you may not know how to tell
me that you love me you may not know how
to show you may not know how to trust
and you trusted once and you got burned
and so you shut that part up great but
you chose to get married again
and by choosing to get married again you
chose
to
become partners again and if you don't
know how to do that it's like this
you're playing football and you blew
your knee out
he said i'm never doing that again cool
but then you got back out on the field
and when you get back on the field you
got to do football stuff and if you're
going to do football stuff that means
you have to go to rehab and learn how to
run again you're going to learn how to
move laterally again and how to jump
again and how to tackle again so he
chose to get married again
great
that means he's gonna have to deal with
what happened
and learn some new things
most the time they don't he could he
could that's my hope man that's my hope
that's my hope that's my hope
[Music]
i'm optimistic this one has a happy
ending but this one's gonna be tough get
with some people today
and for the first time
let your needs be heard speak them out
loud here's what i need not with
laughing that's how you cover it up
don't laugh just say this is what i need
this is what hurts
then really get clear about your or what
statement
[Music]
oh man
this one's hard we'll be right back
hey what's up daloni here i've got a
word from our sponsor better help i'm
always getting calls about burnout what
it is what to do about it and just how
to live feeling this way
burnout is when your body has enough and
it says i'm out i'm done it's that deep
feeling of exhaustion after a long
period of being overworked and
overstressed and just fried and most of
us associate burnout with work but
burnout can happen at any area of our
lives and it can cause a lack of
motivation irritability fatigue or
randomly crying at some random song on
the radio or when somebody looks at you
the wrong way and that's why i love my
friends at betterhelp betterhelp online
therapy exists to give you the chance to
invest in your healing betterhelp is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with you and your therapist you never
have to even see anyone on camera if you
don't want to it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with the therapist in under 48
hours and today our listeners get 10 off
their first month at betterhelp.com
delony that's betterhelphelp.com
all right let's go to
austin texas
what's up jeremy what's up john how you
doing man i'm hey we're partying and you
guys are yeah it's a thousand degrees
there man what are you doing yeah yeah
the weather we kind of we kind of
skipped uh old spring and just jumped
right into late august it's kind of uh
yeah it's you know we're staying inside
i was there a few weeks ago it was
something else man like i grew up in
texas and i was like this is not texas
hot this is
hell hot this is hot hot yeah yeah
it's kind of ridiculous it's you know
everyone
yeah everyone that's older than me like
keeps saying oh it just reminds me 1980
i'm like
i wasn't alive then but i didn't get hot
enough to remember that specific date
cool thanks man that uh cool cool that's
great all right so what's up man what's
up exactly yeah so
uh i'm
kind of trying to figure out how to plan
my eight-month-old first
birthday or first year birthday party uh
which sounds uh relatively simple but my
my wife and i keep getting stuck on the
question of what to do with our
parents so his our son's grandparents
which both of our my parents are
divorced my wife's parents are divorced
and
uh didn't think about having divorced
grandparents oh you got a bunch of
grandparents don't you
yeah six
six and you know potentially in the
future maybe eight so
why not man why not
yeah so like we dealt with that as kids
and that that story is you know
unfortunately pretty common but i hadn't
ever thought in my life the same way we
hadn't thought about
what that looks like for grandkids or
even how to deal with those situations
and we really really want to avoid
those kind of
pains and
the
you know everything that goes along with
the divorce for for children we do not
want our son to even get a hint of that
so
part of it is like what do we do with
these
these events so like starting very
practically with
his
some of these
grandparents like these sort of events
and they like you know they're really
big on it
so initially we're like let's just
invite them all and
tell them to suck it up
and then i would think wouldn't that be
awful if they all showed up
okay so
here let me let me give you a couple of
quick things you can do to frame this
whole thing
okay okay yeah please
number one
a birthday is the way you tell somebody
you love them
yeah it is not a
a an event to show the world how rich
you are how cool and creative you are
or
it's not an event for honoring
grandparents they get their birthday
and so yeah absolutely start the
planning of this thing by taking them
completely out of the picture
okay
how can we best honor this little
one-year-old kid
and that might be a couple of friends
that might be going to the zoo that
might be and this is gonna sound crazy
that might be getting a
hose and letting it run in the backyard
for 20 minutes and making a big mud hole
and y'all just sitting in it with him
and then getting some cupcakes perfect
you know what i mean like your
one-year-old will think that's the
greatest party ever and then when
they're looking at pictures and they're
10 and they're like what is that like
that's when we had a mudhole birthday
and and the 10 year old will go that's
amazing and then the 18 year old would
be like do we really have a mudhole
birthday and you'll be like yes number
one we have 111 grandparents and we
didn't want to deal with it number two
you love mud holes
you see what i'm saying
yeah so and i guess i guess the rest of
my question would be like
i guess all of it the rest of it is
boundaries they're gonna be like hey we
wanna we wanna have a party at our house
and we wanna have a party at our house
and then so here's a beautiful thing
we're not going anywhere okay i want you
to repeat after me it's gonna be amazing
okay all right take a big deep breath
and hold it
hold it one mississippi two mississippi
threes okay let it out
are you ready
yeah repeat after me
no thank you
no thank you or even better
we're not going to be able to make that
this year but we will consider it next
year
yeah that's that's a that's a good one
okay so that one a lot actually yes you
should
so
um
your both of your your parents have made
choices in their life for various
reasons
right and those choices have
consequences that extend beyond time my
dad used to tell me to picture all of my
choices like throwing a rock in the
middle of a lake and those ripples just
keep ripping out and they end up on
different parts of the shore of that
pond
minutes and sometimes hours later right
so
they made choices and they continue to
make choices
your child your eight-month-old
is not in service to the choices they
have
made absolutely yeah okay and neither is
your young marriage and neither is your
parenting
and so here's in all honesty here's how
i would handle this
okay i would get with my wife and say
what do we want to do this year that
will best honor our one-year-old
i think having family involved honors a
one-year-old right it's generational
it's all those things
um
what is the best way we can do that are
the adults in our life mature
do they act like morons are they going
to act in because if they are going to
show up in pick fights and so-and-so is
going to be drinking and
uncle so-and-so is going to be smoking
marble reds in the living room whatever
the thing is
um
that's not honoring that one-year-old
right right so it may be that you send
an email email out to everyone and say
we are not going to split up and do 50
different birthday parties we're gonna
do one
if you can be adults and everybody show
up at the same time
then you're all welcome at our house at
this time and we're gonna have hot dogs
and cake and it's over at three
that's it it's over
if you can't then great
no worries
and i would leave it at that
yeah or the adults about it that's right
or we are choosing to have a friend's
only birthday this year for the
one-year-old birthday
um we'd like to celebrate birthday with
you so at christmas when we come visit
or when y'all come visit we're happy to
celebrate the birthday event
and that will be it that would be the
half birthday they're like a reverse
half birthday i guess
yeah yeah yeah um but it's establishing
those boundaries and then do not budge
and this is your is this kid number one
it is kid number one okay so it's kid
number one and birthday number one so
when you put these boundaries up expect
there to be grenades and missiles and
all kind of bulldozers slamming up
against your boundaries to see if they
hold
for sure there will be adult temper
tantrums there will be all the things
this is about honoring that kid
and one other quick piece of advice for
you
yeah absolutely
you cannot hide the fact that there's
divorce in your family from your child
right yeah yeah we're not trying to hide
the fact necessarily just be
the
i guess it's just a fear of like him
having to go through the things that we
did and right that's just a matter of my
wife and i not getting divorced really
exactly you all have a work really hard
in your great marriage and by the way
setting boundaries like this together
is one of those tactile ways to solidify
your marriage right yeah for sure it's a
it's a coin in the in the bank right so
that's where that team bond really
develops yes and so play the scenario
out with your wife you all can make a
fun game with this um
or it could be a teary mess of a game
uh because
all of us have that picture of that
first birthday and all the adults are
around and they all got just the right
gift and everybody's pulling out candles
everybody's acting mature and then
there's reality
and it may be i'm in favor of the mud
hole man honestly like i think
i grew up i'm not a fan of birthdays my
wife is into birthdays and
uh her side of the family is and
everything so like a lot of that
pressure is just you know birthdays are
important i'm like ah it's just a you
know another spin around the sun but i
think what you're saying about it being
a marker of honoring our son
is a really really good way of thinking
of it
i i i i think
birthdays and funerals
are
moments to pause
and let somebody know i love you
that's why you never miss a funeral
because like a birthday everybody
gathers in a room to say we love this
person
and birthdays are similar
and if people cannot act i don't care
who they are if they can't act with
maturity and they can't act not for
their own sense of self but
on behalf of this little one
and this little one's gonna turn out to
be a 17 year old right and people like
people buy crazy gifts but they buy
gifts because they have turned it into a
competition um i've talked to folks
whose in-laws like compete to buying
presents one in-law is super wealthy
one's not there's a million different
versions of this yeah
all those dynamics exist in this
situation of course i don't like we
don't want to we don't want to deal with
any of that stuff so we're just going to
opt out and it might be this
it might be that you say we're going to
alternate year after year and so just
like in my family we do thanksgiving one
and we do christmas the other me and my
wife do with our our separate families
and then this is part of that yeah
this year i think we're gonna we're
gonna blow it off sorry right
this year i think we're going to blow it
off and we're going to um we're going to
go do christmas like just with me and my
wife and our two little kids we're going
to like go on a trip we've never done
that yeah that's how we do right it's
our life we can do whatever we want to
with it right
exactly exactly and so it may be that
hey this year we celebrate it with this
side of the family and next year y'all
this side of the family gets invited to
the birthday party but
all that to say is let's start with that
one window and then work backwards is
that fair right and i imagine at some
point you know our son is we're going to
give him agency into some of these
decisions about what he wants to do for
his birthday but you know for this first
one that's our first kid and you know
we're just
trying to be as intentional as possible
with you know
to expose them to as much love as
possible but also balances between the
crazies right so because these are these
are all off his grandparents love him
love and love him of course no doubt in
my mind about that it's just you know to
all these histories that they've you
know what you're talking about with the
ripples in the pond
uh
has come down to the third generation so
we're trying to figure that out and it
may be man it may be one of those
shape-shifter moments for your family
but a joint email
from you and your wife to everybody
that was just called it out i don't know
if i recommend this i'm just gonna think
out loud real quick but just call out
we're all adults here
we all me and
wife her wife and husband grew up as
children of divorced parents it was hard
there was lots of back and forth there
was lots of chaos there was lots of
fights there was lots of new marriages
there's lots of new girlfriends and
boyfriends whatever whatever y'all story
is
the key there's chaos
the key there is
angst and we have committed to not
putting our kids through what we
experienced now you saying that out loud
is gonna put your parents on the
defensive
you me yes that happened they have to
own that yep
we got divorced for whatever what's
because billy slept with susan i don't
care why it happened it happened
and we're committed to not doing that so
if y'all can show up to a birthday party
and be adults no presents allowed none
no presents we do not want your gifts
here we're fine
uh if you want to have a gift put an
endowment in a college fund i've opened
to 528 you're free to put money into
that that's going to be his gifts
forever
if y'all can show up and everybody's
here and everybody's smiling and
everybody's fun and there's no tension
great
if you can't you can't
cool we're just not gonna have you and
we'll see you at christmas or we'll see
you at thanksgiving
and if you're gonna act super immature
or be abusive for the song i ever see
um there's something powerful about that
it will cause problems make no mistake
about it it will cause problems but
there's something that's just like i
don't know man i kind of like it like
this is just where we are this is where
we are
but all i have to say is get with your
wife and you'll get really specific how
can we honor this little one how can we
show this this this this little one your
wife's right by the way celebrate
birthdays man they're important we love
you we love you
and then set those boundaries with the
family
and then
hold firm because they're coming we'll
be right back
it seems so easy but most of us way
undervalue real genuine relationships
our friendships our marriages we don't
know what we're doing and instead of
diving into the mess we accept
shallowness and distraction and we
wallpaper over our loneliness so let me
say this boldly you cannot be well alone
you've got to get connected to real life
people and have deep powerful
relationships i'm talking about
relationships where you can be honest
where you can open up or you can share
hard things and you each know that
you'll still show up for each other and
in my new book own your past change your
future we'll walk through a not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness and getting
connected is a key part of that that's
why you'll learn shallowness and
loneliness are so dangerous and more
importantly you'll learn how to create
meaningful relationships in your life
moving forward there is no good app to
help adults find friendships but this
book can help go to johndaloni.com to
take the next step towards wellness
that's own your past change your future
at johndaloni.com
all right we are back and i'm an idiot
listen it's a 529 plan i know this i
know this they're probably gonna put
some graphic making fun of me 529
529
um that would have been one of those
cool things you could have told me real
time but whatever
geez one number off
i let the team down but as we wrap up
today's show i want to thank this
massive studio audience of three
and it's always so weird to talk about
sex to callers in front of parents and
their kids it just always makes me have
the heebie jeebs but good luck to you i
hope y'all hope your lunchtime
discussions are fun
the song is by uh the uh great band the
civil wars
please good folks come back come back to
us civil wars the song's called oh henry
and it goes like this
oh the grass is green everywhere but
under me are so it seems i got a wedding
band in the name of a wandering man i
love the best i can oh henry have you
got something to tell me because
everybody's been saying you've been
running around oh henry i know you
wouldn't hurt me don't you know that we
don't need one more grave in this town
if you're smart you'll know
only
you'll know you'll only have my heart
till death do us part
that's a good song we'll see you soon
coming up on the next episode the last
dr john dolone show ever you want to
know why because we're going skydiving
i want you all to know it's been fun
it's been super super fun
on my job site i spoke during safety
week about my experience with mental
health and anxiety and i've gotten a lot
of really good responses out of it dude
you had a
mental health conversation with
construction workers yep yep there are a
few people i assigned the word hero to
and what you did was heroic my mom saw
something on tv and she said could you
buy me this i was like yeah i'll buy it
for you so i went to go buy it and come
to find out
her debit card client she let him hang
on to her debit card and they've been
spending all of her money for the last
two years and their rents
and their car payments on everything in
their
world
i just don't know what i can do to tell
my mom because my mom keeps trying to
call him he's not answering here's the
faults the full stop truth okay your
brother's a thief
and he's not a person of honor